un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un cordial saludo desde parís les damos
la bienvenida una vez más a este
programa en el que exploramos la
actualidad cultural y hoy en carrusel
los llevamos a ver arte plástico cine y
música conoceremos a la fe électricité
del francés jaula wifi una pintura
monumental de 600 metros cuadrados que
puede visitarse en parís
la cartelera cinematográfica en francia
incluye la historia de un hombre de
personalidad oscura y nos traslada
también a los años 80 en américa latina
a través de la película colombiana el
olvido que seremos y julián a un clásico
peruano
y en nuestra crónica musical iremos al
paraíso del cantante yo sé quién
reivindica y defiende su doble cultura
franco-portuguesa
no
comenzamos nuestro programa contándoles
la increíble historia de la electricidad
desde la antigüedad hasta principios del
siglo 20 pero a través de una pintura se
llama la fe électricité helada
electricidad y es una oda pintada por el
francés haul wifi para la exposición
universal de 1937 en parís esta obra
monumental se encuentra en el museo de
arte moderno de la capital francesa
museo que abrió sus puertas a carrusel
de las artes
son 60 metros de largo por 10 de alto
que cuentan en pintura la conquista de
la electricidad la fe électricité es la
obra maestra de raúl wifi para la
exposición universal de 1937 una
composición monumental donde vivía socio
naturaleza y tecnología y resumió la
historia desde el rayo de zeus hasta las
centrales eléctricas creadas por el
hombre
y
en ese entonces gobernaba el frente
popular que deseaba mostrar una francia
moderna y representó los avances
tecnológicos vinculados a la
electricidad el aeropuerto de borge que
acaba de inaugurarse de este lado los
avisos luminosos en las ciudades que
eran una especialidad francesa con la
orquesta sinfónica que se pudo escuchar
a distancia con la primera difusión
radiofónica algo nuevo en los hogares
franceses número 2 jorge difonso la fe
électricité fue durante 50 años la
pintura más grande del mundo y sin
embargo dif y la ejecutó en apenas 10
meses
cualquiera puede pintar 600 metros
cuadrados en menos de un año pero wifi
fue muy ingenioso por un lado su amigo
el químico jack mccoy e inventó una
pintura muy ligera y fácil de aplicar y
que tenía el aspecto de la acuarela por
otro lado utilizó la técnica de la
linterna
mágica primero dibujaba sus figuras y
luego las proyectaba sobre el soporte
además trabajo sobre láminas
minuciosamente cortadas de 2 metros por
50 centímetros para un total de 600
metros cuadrados y sobre esas siete
expongo raúl y íntegro en su composición
los retratos de 110 sabios que
contribuyeron al desarrollo de la
electricidad así como a los que trabajan
para hacerla posible
cómo se dejan representados desde
arquímedes hasta amperio pasando por
fajas de edición hay una sola mujer
magic lo hay y también un pequeño
personaje azul que representa a los
obreros que hacen funcionar las plantas
eléctricas fue un mensaje muy importante
que difícil transmitió en su obra
wi-fi y terminó exhausto y enfermo con
una pole artritis que se manifestó poco
tiempo después y que lo obligó a poner
fin a su carrera durante la guerra
la fe électricité fue objeto en 2021 de
una limpieza general después de haber
sido fotografiada minuciosamente con
drones esta operación permitió revelar
los colores vivos y transparentes que
empleó wifi
[Música]
pasamos a hablarles ahora de cine porque
este año volver a la prestigiosa
alfombra roja del festival de cannes
será el año de la revancha para este
certamen que debió anular su edición el
año pasado debido a la crisis sanitaria
en 2021 23 cintas competirán por la
palma de oro el máximo galardón de este
certamen en la riviera francesa y entre
las candidatas una cinta filmada en
colombia' memoria dirigida por el
director tailandés apichatpong
weerasethakul y protagonizada por la
vedette tilda swinton le recordamos que
carrusel de las artes estará en cannes
para este festival que tendrá lugar de
manera excepcional del 6 al 17 de julio
y damos ahora una mirada a la cartelera
de los cines en francia en la que
encontramos dos dramas latinoamericanos
y un thriller francés nos amplía melissa
barra
enseñar he enseñado tiempo
llega a las salas de cine francesas la
muy esperada cinta colombiana el olvido
que seremos basada en la novela del
mismo nombre de héctor abad faciolince
fuiste el primero que se atrevió a
hablar de salud pública en este país
esta conmovedora historia familiar se
desarrolla en medellín entre 1960 y
finales de los 80 el escritor cuenta la
trayectoria de su padre héctor abad
gómez un médico comprometido con la
salud pública en colombia a pesar de las
amenazas abad gómez denuncia la
corrupción y el hambre en un país con
enormes brechas sociales la cinta
dirigida por el español fernando trueba
y protagonizada por javier cámara estuvo
en la selección de cannes 2020 ningún
problema sólo de los demás
[Música]
a los cines franceses proyectan también
juliana película peruana de 1989 de
alejandro les gap y fernando espinoza
juliana es el retrato de una infancia
maltratada a través de esta chica que
decide cambiar su identidad y hacerse
una nueva familia con otros jóvenes en
la calle
pero no
[Música]
duncan jones dice tan mal
entre las cintas francesas destacamos un
thriller voy a de peter dosis película
que explora los laberintos de un hombre
perverso
telecom
tras cumplir su condena regresa a la
vida social dispuesto a utilizar su
encanto para abrirse camino y aprovecha
cualquier ocasión para trabajar seducir
y matar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahora ya de hablarles de música con
natalio olivares y esta vez natalia
conociste un artista franco portugués
que ha hecho de esa doble cultura un
tema para sus canciones así es maria
carolina en nuestros paseos musicales
por parís por los barrios de parís nos
llevaron directamente hacia él
bien
en el barrio 2 de la capital conocido
por sus pasajes peatonales nos vamos a
ir a ver a un artista que es vocalista
de stuck in the sound este grupo mítico
que seguirá pero que decidió asumirse
como solista con su nuevo álbum paraíso
[Música]
tanto en portugués en un idioma que para
mí es curiosamente más íntimo cuando
empiezo a hablar en portugués ya no soy
la misma persona en portugal soy jose y
por lo tanto eso significa que estoy
bien con mis padres con los recuerdos de
mi infancia la familia algo muy personal
y muy íntimos eisner esta noche
imagen del álbum es un clavel símbolo de
la liberación de la dictadura de
portugal el 25 de abril de 1974 la
revolución de los claveles pues para mí
este disco se refiere a esta sensación
de libertad y a través de temas que me
son muy cercanos como el romanticismo
como la madeleine de pus o como la
saudade
los soldados
[Música]
y más allá de descubrir a un artista
lleno de emociones lleno de recuerdos de
ese país portugal que descubrimos
también un disco primer disco escrito en
parte en portugués como un homenaje a
ese país
portugal nuevamente ya sus eventos
históricos como la revolución de los
claveles la revolución que liberó el
pueblo portugués de la dictadura de
salazar y natalia que significa dada
dada primero es importante porque es el
primer extracto de este disco primer
disco y es también y sobre todo el apodo
que le dio a su abuela la persona con
quien pasó la mayor parte de sus veranos
en portugal un pilar para él un pilar
para su música
así como hay un lado funky y también un
lado trágico en este álbum porque hablo
de mi abuela que acaba de fallecer mi
abuela era el pilar de la familia y una
de las personas más importantes para mí
esta canción me permitió también dar un
giro como artista cuando compuse esta
canción escribí la letra y lloré después
de cantar pero
es muy muy íntimo y en este momento me
di cuenta de lo poderoso que es hacer
canciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
porque lo que lo que quiero
brillando de una canción también muy
importante porque dice cuán ecléctico es
ese disco primero disco cuando ecléctico
y le da el aporte electro del aporte el
aporte festivo en insertado en un disco
escrito con sonoridades del fado
portugués por ejemplo de las audaces de
brasil y de la balada francesa beyond
out es la parte electro de ese disco y
recordemos que yo sé natalia es el líder
de esta banda de rock era como tú lo
decías stacking the sound que preparan
nuevas canciones está a 15 savané
efectivamente ayude es un trabajólico
mientras marca una pausa es el grupo
prepara un nuevo álbum solo solitario
como lo hicimos lo dijimos en primero
disco y ahora además prepara nuevas
canciones para preparar el regreso de la
banda previsto para septiembre gracias
natal y bueno vamos a escuchar un
poquito más de esa música de ellos de
los dejamos con dada para despedir este
carrusel de las artes muchísimas gracias
por su sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
bien
a mí
[Música]
sí
como sea
y a
[Música]
así